Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History, the second part of our coverage of the World Cup of Gods 2021, which was running all last week on Twitter. In the first episode, if you listened to that, you'll know that we talked about the group matches. We discussed the gods that got knocked out. So that was Moloch, Chippy Totec, Ishtar, Bridget, Augustus Caesar, Loki, Kibale, and very sadly, Prince Philip.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，这是我们对2021年诸神世界杯报道的第二部分。上周整个星期，这项赛事一直在推特上进行。如果你听过第一集，就会知道我们讨论了小组赛。我们讨论了被淘汰的神明：摩洛克（Moloch）、西佩·托特克（Xipe Totec）、伊什塔尔（Ishtar）、布丽吉特（Bridget）、奥古斯都·凯撒（Augustus Caesar）、洛基（Loki）、库柏勒（Cybele），以及非常遗憾的菲利普亲王（Prince Philip）。
In today's episode, we're going to go through the quarterfinals, the semififinals and then the final uh and with me is my co-presenter co-sports analyst dominic sandbrook saints and greavesy of uh saints and gravy of um of uh world cup divine sport um and so dominic moving into the into the quarterfinals we had zeus against athena mithras against dionysus anubis against Isis, Apollo against Odin, talking points around all of them. Shall we focus in on the familial clash that was Zeus against Athena? So father and daughter. What was your take on that? Yes.
在今天的节目中，我们将回顾四分之一决赛、半决赛以及决赛。与我同行的是我的联合主持人、联合体育分析师多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），他简直就是神界体育领域的“圣徒与格里夫斯”（Saints and Greavesy）……那么，多米尼克，进入四分之一决赛后，我们有宙斯对阵雅典娜、密特拉对阵狄奥尼索斯、阿努比斯对阵伊西斯、阿波罗对阵奥丁，这些对决都有很多看点。我们要不要把焦点放在宙斯对阵雅典娜这场家族冲突上？也就是父亲和女儿。你对此有什么看法？是的。
So I thought Athena was going to win that particular tie. And of course she did. She's born from Zeus's head. So as Jonathan Wilson said in his preview, she'd given him a headache in the past, and she did so again. The funny thing is, you know, Zeus, a lot of people said at the beginning,
所以，我原以为雅典娜会赢得这场比赛。当然，她也确实赢了。她是从宙斯的头颅里蹦出来的。正如乔纳森·威尔逊（Jonathan Wilson）在他的前瞻中所说，她过去曾让宙斯头疼过，而这次她又做到了。有趣的是，你知道的，宙斯，很多人在开始时都说……
well, Zeus will win it, because he's probably the most... Alpha male. It's the most famous, isn't he? He's a god that everybody knows. But I find Zeus quite boring. Do you? I do.
嗯，宙斯会赢的，因为他可能是最具……alpha男气质的。他是最著名的，不是吗？他是个人人皆知的神。但我发现宙斯挺无聊的。是吗？我是这么觉得的。
There's not... He doesn't... He's always plunging down. Yes. Had 150 affairs. Yeah, exactly. His sort of modus operandi is he transforms himself into a bull. An animal.
没有什么……他没什么……他总是从天而降。是的。有过150段风流韵事。对，没错。他的一种行事方式就是把自己变成一头公牛。某种动物。
An animal or something, and impregnates somebody, and then just goes back to Olympus again to face the wrath of Hera. But ultimately, I find that quite a repetitive story. And he's not... To me, Zeus doesn't seem to have some of the weird complexity of some of the gods we discussed on the last podcast. We talked about Cybele, for example, and nearly had strokes brought on by hysterics.
某种动物或其他东西，让某人怀孕，然后又回到奥林匹斯山去面对赫拉的狂怒。但归根结底，我觉得这是一个非常重复的故事。而且他……对我来说，宙斯似乎缺乏我们在上一期播客中讨论过的一些神明那种奇特的复杂性。比如我们讨论过的库柏勒（Cybele），差点让人由于歇斯底里而中风。
But with Zeus, I mean, Zeus seems to be quite a humorless figure. Do you think that's fair, Tom? I think I'm being too harsh. Turning yourself into a swan or a bull. I mean, I mean, it's faintly sinister. I mean, it's a bit pervy, but I don't think it's boring. In the age of Me Too, maybe Zeus would always face... Oh, I mean, it seems to be massively cancelled but
但说到宙斯，我的意思是，宙斯似乎是一个相当缺乏幽默感的人物。你觉得这公平吗，汤姆？我觉得自己是不是太严苛了。把自己变成一只天鹅或公牛。我的意思是，我的意思是，这隐隐有些阴险。我的意思是，这有点色迷迷的，但我不觉得它无聊。在“我也是”（Me Too）运动的时代，也许宙斯会永远面临……哦，我的意思是，他似乎会被大规模取消，但是
yeah but but he'd also be cancelled as as a kind of prime patriarch because he's the model of an indo-european sky god yeah and also isn't he i mean he's your father but he's so so his name uh zeus patter um sky father yeah you still get you know the full the full title in Jupiter and you get it in Sanskrit too, apparently. So he knocks off the pater bit, the father bit, it just becomes Zeus. But he's absolutely the embodiment of this,
对，但但作为一个初代大家长，他也会被取消，因为他是印欧天空之神的原型。是的，而且难道不是吗？我的意思是，他是你的父亲，但他又是如此的……所以他的名字，嗯，宙斯·帕特（Zeus pater），天空之父亲。是的，你仍然能在“朱庇特”（Jupiter）这个全称中看到这一点，而且显然在梵语中也能看到。所以他去掉了“帕特”这个词，也就是父亲的意思，只剩下了“宙斯”。但他绝对是这种形象的化身，
the god of the sky who rules the universe. Let's talk about Zeus and Jupiter a little bit because he's a good opportunity to talk about. People generally think of the Greek and Roman gods as identical, don't they? But is that wrong? So Zeus is the classic example. Zeus and Jupiter, they basically have the same name.
统治宇宙的天空之神。我们来多聊聊宙斯和朱庇特，因为他是一个很好的切入点，可以让我们谈谈人们通常认为希腊神话和罗马神话中的神是完全相同的，对吧？但这种看法是错的吗？所以宙斯就是一个典型的例子。宙斯和朱庇特，他们基本上拥有相同的名字。
So they clearly reflect Indo-European traditions that have been brought to Greece and Italy, respectively. By and large, the Roman gods are less fleshed out than the greek ones because the greek ones are fleshed out by homer first of all and then by the tragedians though interestingly zeus is the only kind of major greek god who doesn't appear on the the tragic stage so that's a kind of measure of i think of his ultimate significance that he can contain entirety in a way that that the other gods can't. But on the Roman thing, the Roman gods, by and large, are less detailed. But when the Romans annex Greece, when they, and even before that, when they're annexing the Greek states in Italy,
所以他们清楚地反映了分别被带到希腊和意大利的印欧传统。大体上说，罗马神话中的神比希腊的更加不够丰满，因为希腊神话中的神首先是由荷马丰满起来的，然后又由悲剧作家们丰满起来——尽管有趣的是，宙斯是唯一一个没有出现在悲剧舞台上的希腊主要神明——所以这在某种程度上衡量了我认为他的终极重要性，即他能够以一种其他神明无法做到的方式包容一切。但就罗马神话而言，罗马的神大体上细节较少。不过，当罗马人吞并希腊时，当他们——甚至在此之前，当他们在意大利吞并希腊城邦时，
you know, Greece is the cultural trendsetter. And so inevitably, the Romans kind of pair up their gods with with the greek gods but you know right the way through into the imperial period jupiter has has a role and a significance and a status that is distinctive within rome that owes nothing really to zeus and what is that then what's that status that's different from his so his temple on the capitol is the most significant temple in Rome. And it's where the most significant annual ritual practices are taken place that help to maintain the spiritual health of Rome.
你知道，希腊是文化的风向标。因此，罗马人不可避免地将他们的神与希腊神话中的神进行配对。但你知道，一直到帝国时期，朱庇特在罗马依然拥有独特的作用、意义和地位，这与宙斯其实毫无关系。那么那是什么呢？那是一个与宙斯不同的地位是什么？所以他在卡皮托利尼山上的神庙是罗马最重要的神庙。
And that's incredibly important. So every year when the consuls are elected, they go up to the Capitol and the auguries are taken in front of Jupiter's temple. That has nothing to do with the stories that are told in Greece about Zeus. Although, obviously, they're conflated. Yeah. I mean, I think Jupiter is properly boring in the sense that he is quite stiff.
正是在那里，举行着最重要的年度仪式活动，这些活动有助于维护罗马的精神健康。这极其重要。因此，每年当执政官当选时，他们都会登上卡皮托利尼山，在朱庇特神庙前进行观鸟占卜（auguries）。这与希腊流传的关于宙斯的故事毫无关系。尽管很明显，它们被融合在了一起。是的。我的意思是，我觉得朱庇特确实很无聊，因为他相当刻板。
Yes. Where I don't think Zeus is boring. I mean, he's Thunderbolts. He's the only guy who can handle Thunderbolts. He's got weapons of mass destruction. He's sleeping around with everybody. He's a bull. He's an eagle. He's an oak. He's got all these children. I mean, so
是的。而我不觉得宙斯无聊。我的意思是，他是雷霆。他是唯一一个能掌控雷霆的人。他拥有大规模杀伤性武器。他跟所有人鬼混。他是一头公牛。他是一只老鹰。他是一棵橡树。他有这么多的孩子。我的意思是，所以
Athena and Apollo, both contestants in this World Cup, are his children. And then he's got all the heroes. And he's got Helen. Helen of Troy is his daughter. Is he almost too powerful, though? Is he so powerful that that makes him a little bit boring to think? Well, what happened? I mean, it's an interesting question that it could be argued that there is a kind of monotheistic trend within polytheism.
雅典娜和阿波罗，这场世界杯的两位参赛者，都是他的孩子。然后他还有所有的英雄。他还有海伦。特洛伊的海伦是他的女儿。不过，他是不是太强大了？他是不是强大到让人觉得有点无聊？好吧，发生了什么？我的意思是，这是一个有趣的问题，可以说在多神教内部存在一种一神教的趋势。
In a sense, what ultimately happens is that, and you see this in India as well, is that gods are simultaneously worshipped as individuals, but ultimately come to be seen as expressions of the one kind of expression of divinity. And in the Greek world, that can only be Zeus. He's the only god who can play that role. Who can contain multitudes. Who can contain multitudes. So I think he's clearly an alpha male, a big player, but perhaps just not his year.
从某种程度上讲，最终发生的是——你在印度也能看到这一点——神明们既作为个体受到崇拜，但最终又被视为同一神性的一种表现形式。在希腊世界里，那只能是宙斯。他是唯一能扮演这个角色的神。一个能包容万千的神。一个能包容万千的神。所以我认为他显然是一个alpha男，一个大人物，但也许只是今年不属于他。
This is not, the 21st century is not his time then, is it? It's not his time, is it not his time is it um all right patriarchal harasser of women is you know he's never going to win the people assumed he was going to win um and for that reason they he was never going to because he was the kind of person who would have won in 1980 but wasn't going to win in 2021 so exit zeus uh and then we had i thought a very interesting clash probably a bit more of a walkover than I was expecting Mithras against Dionysus now Mithras
这不是，21世纪不是属于他的时代，对吧？这不是他的时代，这不是他的时代吗，嗯……好吧，女性的宗法骚扰者（指宙斯），你知道的，他是永远不可能赢得比赛的。人们以为他会赢，正因为如此，他才永远不可能赢，因为他是那种在1980年会赢，但在2021年绝不会赢的人。所以，宙斯出局。然后我们迎来了——我认为是一场非常有趣的对决，可能比我预期的要更一边倒——密特拉对阵狄奥尼索斯。现在说到密特拉，
he's a fascinating god I think I think he's incredibly boring this is very strange because we completely disagree on this why do you think he's interesting because he's so mysterious and also because he's sort of a bit of a rotary club character I like that I like that last bit there speaks a man who's written because he's so mysterious and also because he's sort of a bit of a Rotary Club character. I like that.
他是一个迷人的神，我认为……我觉得他极其无聊。这太奇怪了，因为我们对此完全持相反意见。你为什么觉得他有趣？因为他太神秘了，而且他有点像扶轮社（Rotary Club）的成员。我喜欢那个，我喜欢最后那句话，这说出了一个曾撰写……因为他太神秘了，而且他有点像扶轮社的成员。我喜欢那个。
I like that last bit. There speaks a man who's written histories of Britain in the 1970s. Yeah, I see him as a very 1970s... He's a very 1970s god. He is. You can imagine him in a sitcom. Yeah. He's coming for supper. Ding dong. Oh, it's Mithra.
我喜欢最后那句话。这话出自一位写过20世纪70年代英国历史的人之口。是的，我觉得他是一个非常70年代的……他是一个非常70年代的神。确实如此。你能想象他在情景喜剧里的样子。是的。他来吃晚饭了。叮咚。哦，是密特拉。
You know, in The Good Life, the people who live next door um paul eddington and penelope keith they're definitely members of them they're definitely members of a mithras sort of aren't they um he's the god of civil servants basically if you're a low-ranking civil servant or an aspiring roman officer yeah you go to so let's let's explain what we mean for those people who think we've just gone mad so okay mithras he it does he or does he not come from iran from persia it's generally seemed that he does because there's a kind of um a large number of a swirl of gods that sound a bit like mithras so there is um an indian god called mitra who's god of the skies
你知道，在《美好生活》（The Good Life）里，住在隔壁的那两口子——嗯，保罗·丁顿（Paul Eddington）和佩内洛普·基斯（Penelope Keith）——他们绝对是那种人，他们绝对是某种密特拉式俱乐部的成员，对吧？嗯……他基本上是公务员的神。如果你是一个低阶公务员或者一个有抱负的罗马军官，是的，你会去……所以，让我们来为那些觉得我们已经疯了的人解释一下我们的意思。好吧，密特拉，他到底是不是来自伊朗、来自波斯？普遍的看法是他是的，因为有一种……有大量听起来有点像密特拉的神明在周围盘旋。所以有一个……
um there's an a persian god called mithra who likewise ends up the god of the skies and they essentially um a bit like jupiter and zeus you know again this is these are indo-european gods in sanskrit and in persian they essentially they're the same um and then what's the relationship of mithras to that um because if mithra the persian god and mithras the roman god are the same then obviously his ultimate origins is persia i i think um that basically mithras is a roman invention um that's what some historians think now isn't it that there's a tenuous link with the east but actually he's really a God for and created in Rome. And the Romans have a deep prejudice against upstart cults.
有一个叫米特拉（Mitra）的印度神，是天空之神；嗯，还有一个叫米特拉（Mithra）的波斯神，同样也是天空之神。他们本质上……有点像朱庇特和宙斯，你知道，同样地，这些都是梵语和波斯语中的印欧神明，他们本质上是同一个神。然后密特拉与此有什么关系呢？因为如果波斯神米特拉和罗马神密特拉是同一个神，那么很显然他的最终起源就是波斯。我……我认为基本上密特拉是一个罗马的发明。这正是现在一些历史学家所认为的，对吧？即与东方有着微弱的联系，但实际上他真正是一个为罗马而生、在罗马创造的神。而且罗马人对暴发户式的邪教有着深深的偏见。
So that's why they're perfectly happy to tolerate, for instance, Jewish worship, because it's authentically ancient, even though the Romans see it as weird, but they regard Christianity as beyond the pale because it's of recent origin. So I think that the Mithras cult, it's astrologically centered. It's about the tracking of recent origin. So I think that the Mithras cult, it's astrologically centered.
所以这就是为什么他们完全乐意容忍例如犹太人的崇拜，因为它是真正古老的，尽管罗马人认为它很诡异；但他们认为基督教是不合常规的，因为它起源于近期。所以我认为密特拉崇拜是以星相学为核心的。它是关于追踪……起源于近期。所以我认为密特拉崇拜是以星相学为核心的。
It's about the tracking of the heavens. But because the people who are developing it don't want it to look like it's an upstart cult, they essentially kind of identify it with Persia, which gives it a sense that it's venerable and ancient. Yeah, a sense of a pattern of kind of authenticity and so basically the way it works is there are these places called mithraeums which are generally i think underground aren't they they're sort of you go to a mithraeum and you generally
它是关于追踪天象的。但由于开发它的人不希望它看起来像是一个暴发户式的邪教，他们本质上将其与波斯联系起来，这赋予了它一种德高望重和古老的感觉。是的，有一种正统性的模式感。所以基本上它的运作方式是，有这样一些被称为密特拉神庙（mithraeums）的地方，它们通常，我认为是在地下的，对吧？你会去一个密特拉神庙，而你通常……
tend to be invited to go if you're a you've joined the roman army you're an officer in the roman army or you're a bureaucrat or something and you're trying to make your way in the world. You get invited by colleague, come to the Mithraeum on Friday night or whenever it is. I don't know when it is. Put on a mask. Yeah. You go to them and there's,
如果你加入了罗马军队、是罗马军队的官佐，或者是个官僚之类的人，并且正试图在社会上混出名堂，你通常会被邀请去。你会受到同事的邀请：周五晚上来密特拉神庙吧，或者诸如此类的。我不知道具体是什么时候。戴上一个面具。是的。你去参加，然后……
roll up a guy's leg. It's that kind of stuff. There's a, there's a sculpture often of a God killing a bull. Yeah. That's all we've found there. There's also a sculpture that nobody's ever been able to explain of a man with a lion's head.
撩起一个家伙的裤腿。就是那种类型的活动。通常会有一尊神明杀死公牛的雕塑。是的。我们在那里发现的就只有这些。还有一个没有人能解释的雕塑，是一个长着狮子头的男人。
People don't know where that fits in, but it does. And you go and you have a banquet and you sort of meet and greet you know middle managers and other you know coming men in the in the room it's men only um like the freemasons yeah and it's i mean there's an argument isn't there among historians that one reason why you know it's got a ceiling it's got an inbuilt ceiling in terms of numbers because it's a cult for sort of middle class kind of you know aspiring bureaucratic kind of people and it has levels that mean yes and there's gradations as initiation just sort of and because of that that means it's never going to become a mass market cult like christianity which is for the common man is that right well? Well, there's often this thing that if the world hadn't become Christian, it would be Mithraic, but it wouldn't. Because it was too much like the Rotary Club, basically.
人们不知道这东西是怎么契合进来的，但它确实在那里。然后你去参加宴会，结识中层管理者和房间里其他……你知道的，有前途的年轻人。这仅限男性参加，就像共济会一样。是的。而且，历史学家之间存在一种争论，对吧？为什么这个教派的规模有一个上限，一个内置的人数上限，因为它是为中产阶级那种……你知道的，有抱负的官僚阶层准备的邪教，并且它有等级制度，这意味着……是的，有入会的阶梯。正因为如此，这意味着它永远不会像基督教那样成为一个大众市场的邪教，因为基督教是为普通人准备的，是这样吗？好吧。总有这样一种说法：如果世界没有皈依基督教，它就会皈依密特拉教。但事实并非如此。因为它太像扶轮社了，基本上。
Because it's too much like the Rotary Club, exactly. But it was very successful. So there's a Mithraic that was found in London that for a long time, they kind of put it with crazy paving in the middle of the city. And now it's beneath the new bloomboat building it's really good strongly recommend it and can you go and see it yeah you can yeah they've done it really well and they've kind of um they use light to show so you've got what does remain the stones and then they use light to show you um what it would what it might have looked like
因为它太像扶轮社了，完全如此。但它非常成功。所以在伦敦发现了一个密特拉神庙，很长一段时间里，人们把它当作市中心的疯狂铺路石（crazy paving）。而现在它在新的彭博（Bloomberg）大楼下面。真的非常棒，强烈推荐。你能去参观吗？对，可以。他们做得非常出色，而且他们用光影来展示……所以你拥有留存下来的石头，然后他们用光影来向你展示……它曾经可能是什么样子。
and also there's a very atmospheric one on hadrian's wall just And it's associated a lot with the army, isn't it? The Roman army. Yeah, so that's why the one on Hadrian's Wall is there. But I think Mithras is boring. I can't believe people haven't brought it back. I think it should come back. I think it's a very great... I mean, if there's a room for the Masons and the Rotary Club,
而且在哈德良长城（Hadrian's Wall）上也有一座极具氛围感的神庙。它和军队有很大的联系，对吧？罗马军队。是的，这就是为什么哈德良长城上会有这么一座。但我认为密特拉很无聊。我简直不敢相信人们没有把它带回来。我觉得它应该回归。我觉得这是一个非常棒的……我的意思是，既然共济会和扶轮社都有其一席之地，
I don't see why there isn't room for Mithras as well, for Mithraeums. I mean, it just is a more exotic version of Masonry. Anyway, Mithras did crash out. He was beaten by Dionysus, so people clearly prefer wine drinking to bull killing. Yes. Which is sad. Right. Now we come to probably the...
我看不出为什么密特拉以及密特拉神庙不能也有一席之地。我的意思是，它只是共济会的一种更具异国情调的版本而已。不管怎样，密特拉确实出局了。他被狄奥尼索斯击败了，所以人们显然更喜欢喝酒而不是杀公牛。是的。这挺让人难过的。好。现在我们来到了可能……
I mean, this match was the huge talking point on Twitter, wasn't it? Anubis against Isis. So what we actually didn't mention last time was that Lockie had only lost by the slimmest of margins to Anubis. The barest of margins. I mean, he'd lost by like three votes or something because it was 50-50 in the percentages.
我的意思是，这场比赛是推特上巨大的热门话题，对吧？阿努比斯对阵伊西斯。所以我们上次其实没有提到的是，洛基仅以微弱的劣势输给了阿努比斯。极其微弱的劣势。我的意思是，他只输了三票左右，因为在百分比上是五五开。
But Anubis clearly had won a couple more votes. So Anubis had been through this incredibly exacting round against Lockie and then he's up against Isis. So Anubis had been through this incredibly exacting round against Loki, and then he's up against Isis. So another ancient Egyptian, an ancient Egyptian goddess, a huge figure. And this was, again, a very tight... Anubis got an early lead, didn't he? And then thanks to your efforts, subverting the competition
但阿努比斯显然多赢了区区几票。所以阿努比斯在经历了一轮与洛基极其艰难的对决之后，又迎来了伊西斯。所以阿努比斯在经历了一轮与洛基极其艰难的对决之后，现在要对阵伊西斯。又是一个古埃及神明，一个古埃及女神，一个重量级人物。这也是一场非常胶着的比赛……阿努比斯早早就取得了领先，对吧？然后多亏了你的努力，颠覆了比赛，
and corrupting the principles of the tournament, Isis won a very narrow and controversial victory. I just felt that it would be better for the sport to have the Queen of the Heavens in the semifinals than a dog. First of all, he's not a dog. He's not a dog. You clearly do have something against dogs because you're a cat person, as is well known.
败坏了锦标赛的原则，伊西斯赢得了一场非常险恶且颇具争议的胜利。我只是觉得，让天国女王进入半决赛，对这项运动来说要比让一条狗进去更好。首先，他不是狗。他不是狗。你显然对狗有成见，因为众所周知你是个猫派人士。
But he's not necessarily a jackal. Because jackals are golden and he's black. No, he's he's a gold he's been reclassified i think as a wolf as a sort of uh so the jackal is is not right so i know a bit about anubis because i made an anubis costume as listeners will know give us tell us why you should have won well he usually had a great name originally he was wet whichp Wah Wet, which I think... You can imagine the chants from the... He's black. The stans.
但他不一定是胡狼。因为胡狼是金黄色的，而他是黑色的。不，他是一条金……我想他已经被重新归类为狼了，作为某种……所以胡狼是不对的。我对阿努比斯略知一二，因为正如听众们所知，我曾制作过一套阿努比斯的服装。给我们讲讲你为什么觉得他应该赢。好吧，他通常有一个伟大的名字。最初他是韦普韦特（Wepwawet），我觉得……你能想象来自……的呐喊声。他的狂热粉丝们。
He's black. Yes, like a corpse. So the colour of death and also the colour of the soil, the fertile soil of the Nile. So he's linked to regeneration. Supposedly, I read that of historians believe that the Egyptians adopted him because wild dogs were digging up their corpses. So that it was obvious you'd need a dog-like protector to ward off the wild dogs.
他是黑色的。是的，就像一具尸体。所以这是死亡的颜色，也是土壤的颜色，尼罗河肥沃的土壤。所以他与再生紧密相连。据我所读到的一位历史学家的观点，古埃及人收养他是因为野狗会刨开他们的尸体。所以很显然，你需要一个像狗一样的保护者来驱赶野狗。
This is one theory. He begins as the son of Ra. Then he evolves into the son of Osiris in the way that Egyptian gods did evolve over the course of Egyptian history. And Osiris, one of the great gods, married his sister Isis. Yes. So he's up against Isis, obviously. And I'll tell you what he is, Tom.
这是一个理论。他最初是拉（Ra）的儿子。后来，按照埃及神明在埃及历史进程中演变的方式，他演变成了奥西里斯（Osiris）的儿子。而奥西里斯是伟大的神明之一，娶了他的妹妹伊西斯。是的。所以他显然要对阵伊西斯。我告诉你他是什么，汤姆。
He's a psychopomp. Yes, he is. A word that I didn't know until this morning existed. A spiritual butler. Yeah. He's present when you die. The psychopomp is the god who accompanies you to the underworld. He doesn't judge you.
他是一个心理导引者（psychopomp）。是的，他是。这个词我直到今天早上才知道它存在。一个灵界管家。是的。当你死的时候他在场。心理导引者是陪伴你前往冥界的神。他不审判你。
He doesn't give you a hard time. So what he is, he's in a tradition that includes Hermes, St. Peter, and DCI Gene Hunt in Life on Mars and Ashes to Ashes. So Gene Hunt is Anubis. And I think that's another reason why Anubis should have won the entire tournament, because Gene Hunt's a great character for those people who've seen Life on Mars. And Anubis is basically the Egyptian Gene Hunt. Because Gene Hunt welcomes 1970s British policemen into purgatory, doesn't he?
他不会让你难堪。所以，他属于这样一个传统：其中包括赫尔墨斯、圣彼得，还有《火星生活》和《灰烬寻踪》里的警务总督吉恩·亨特。所以吉恩·亨特就是阿努比斯。我认为这也是阿努比斯应该赢得整个锦标赛的另一个原因，因为对于看过《火星生活》的人来说，吉恩·亨特是一个极棒的角色。而阿努比斯基本上就是埃及的吉恩·亨特。因为吉恩·亨特欢迎20世纪70年代的英国警察来到炼狱，不是吗？
I'm so impressed with your ability to get a discussion of 1970s policing into a podcast on ancient gods. It's great. So anyway, all this is why Anubis is such an interesting figure. The sad thing about Anubis is there's no stories attached to him. Well, there is, isn't there? Because so he, in the kind of the more recent stories about him, by more recent, I kind of mean.
我太佩服你能把关于20世纪70年代警务的讨论塞进一档关于古代神明的播客里了。这太棒了。不管怎样，所有这些都说明了为什么阿努比斯是一个如此有趣的人物。关于阿努比斯，令人遗憾的是，没有任何与之相关的神话故事。好吧，其实是有的，对吧？因为在关于他的那些相对较新的故事中——所谓的“较新”，我大致是指……
When you say more recent. 3,000 years ago. Yeah. He is the child. So Osiris is married to Isis. And their sister, Nephthys, is married to seth who is the kind of i suppose the loki he's the baddie isn't he he's the baddie who who then kills osiris but uh osiris prior to this has um had sex with nephthys and give an anubis as the result of this with his daughter is that
当你说“较新”时。3000年前。是的。他是这个孩子。欧西里斯娶了伊西丝。他们的妹妹奈芙蒂斯嫁给了赛特，赛特大概就像是——我猜——洛基那样的人，他是坏蛋，对吧，他是个坏蛋，后来杀害了欧西里斯；但是，呃，在此之前，欧西里斯曾与奈芙蒂斯发生过关系，并因此生下了阿努比斯。和他的女儿，是这样吗？
no his sister oh his sister sorry yes i've got um and isis is the result of this. With his daughter, is that? No, his sister. Oh, his sister. Sorry, yes. And Isis, no hard feelings about this. Your brother-husband has slept with your sister. Doesn't seem too fazed by this. And brings Anubis up. So she's his stepmother. And then when Osiris gets killed by Seth, and we'll come to this when we talk about Isis,
不，是他的妹妹。哦，是他的妹妹，抱歉，是的。我弄错了……而伊西丝——对此没有任何怨言。你的兄弟兼丈夫和你的妹妹睡了。她似乎对此并不怎么介意，并且把阿努比斯抚养长大。所以她是他的继母。然后当欧西里斯被赛特杀害时——我们在谈论伊西丝时会讲到这一点——
Anubis wraps him up and embalms him and makes Osiris into the first mummy. Yes, he's the god of mummification. He's the god of embalmment. So he invents the mummy, basically. And I think that's the key story. But I agree. I mean, aside from that, I think he's not very interesting. Whereas Isis is a lot more interesting.
阿努比斯为他包裹尸体、进行防腐处理，把欧西里斯变成了第一具木乃伊。是的，他是木乃伊之神。他是防腐之神。所以他基本上发明了木乃伊。我认为这是最关键的故事。但我同意。我的意思是，除此之外，我认为他并没有那么有趣。相比之下，伊西丝要有趣得多。
I think Anubis has an immense appeal to children because of his dog head. And also he's appeared in loads of kind of films, hasn't he? And computer games. Well, he's just become a sort of emblem of ancient Egypt. Yes. In a way that's probably not true of...
我认为阿努比斯因为他那颗狗头，对孩子们有着巨大的吸引力。而且他还在大量的电影中出现过，对吧？还有电脑游戏。没错，他简直成了古埃及的一种象征。是的。从某种程度上说，这可能不适用于……
I mean, how many Egyptian gods... Egyptian gods are fascinating but how many of them do people remember? Three? Four? And Anubis is always one of them because of the canine. And Horus, I guess, is the other because he's got a head of a hawk. Yeah, exactly. So my son made a horse costume. When he was doing what I did when I was five or six, he made a horse costume.
我的意思是，有多少埃及神明……埃及神明虽然引人入胜，但人们能记住的有几个？三个？四个？而因为那个犬科动物的头部，阿努比斯总是其中之一。我猜荷鲁斯是另一个，因为他长着一张鹰头。对，完全正确。所以我的儿子制作了一个马的服装。当他在做我五六岁时做过的事时，他做了一个马的服装。
I made an Anubis. Did you ever make an Egyptian costume, Tom? No, I didn't. I missed out on this rite of passage. Yeah, I missed out on that. It's obviously a Midlands thing must be
我制作了一个阿努比斯。汤姆，你做过埃及服装吗？不，我没有。我错过了这个成年礼。是的，我错过了。这显然是米德兰兹地区的特色，肯定是。
must be yes all right so Anubis was defeated in very controversial circumstances
肯定是，没错。好了，所以阿努比斯是在极具争议的情况下被淘汰的。
I think when we have future World Cups there will clearly have to be a code of conduct about the judges
我认为在我们举办未来的世界杯时，显然必须为裁判制定行为准则。
or the organisers not getting involved in I did what I did for the benefit of the sport
或者说组织者不应该介入其中。我做我做的事是为了这项运动的利益。
well that's Sepp Latta I mean that's what Sepp Latta says. Fine. That's what Florentino Perez says at Real Madrid. The Super League. The sport, c'est moi.
好吧，那是塞普·布拉特。我的意思是，那是塞普·布拉特会说的话。好吧。那是弗洛伦蒂诺·佩雷斯在皇家马德里会说的话。超级联赛。这项运动就是我。
Yeah, clearly. All right. Let's do one more goal before the break. And let's do Apollo. It's Apollo against Odin. Yeah, Apollo against Odin. Now, Apollo, to me... And Odin won.
是的，很明显。好吧。在中场休息前再进一个球吧。我们选阿波罗吧。这是阿波罗对阵奥丁。是的，阿波罗对阵奥丁。现在，在我看来，阿波罗……而奥丁赢了。
...is quite comfortably. Yeah, I was surprisedin. Now, Apollo to me... And Odin won. Quite comfortably. Yeah, I was surprised by that. I mean, surprisingly comfortably. Now, Apollo to me is the absolute epitome of a Greek god. I mean, he is the statue that seems to symbolise ancient Greece. And yet, what is it about him I wonder? Is it a blandness, a perceived blandness? He's not bland though.
……赢得相当轻松。是的，我对此感到惊讶。现在，在我看来，阿波罗……而奥丁赢了。赢得相当轻松。是的，我对此外感到惊讶。我的意思是，赢得未免太轻松了。现在，在我看来，阿波罗是希腊神明的绝对缩影。我的意思是，他就是那尊似乎象征着古希腊的雕像。然而，关于他，我究竟在想什么呢？是一种平淡吗，一种人们认为的平淡？不过他并不平淡。
I mean, he's terrifying. Well, I don't think he's bland, people uh the voters didn't go for him i think i think odin is is a kind of very popular figure because he's again he's got that kind of slight computer game yeah edge to him which apollo doesn't really have which apollo doesn't and i think also apollo is kind of associated with a slightly chilly 18th century classicism. Yeah, that's what I meant, I guess. So I guess in the kind of the 18th century, the Apollo Belvedere was seen as being the most beautiful statue in the world
我的意思是，他令人毛骨悚然。好吧，我不认为他平淡，人们——选民们并没有选择他。我认为，我认为奥丁是一个非常受欢迎的人物，因为他同样具有那种轻微的电脑游戏般的边缘感，而阿波罗并没有这种感觉——而阿波罗没有。并且我认为阿波罗也带有一种略显冷清的18世纪古典主义色彩。是的，我想我就是这个意思。所以我想在18世纪左右，贝尔维德雷的阿波罗被视为世界上最美丽的雕像。
and nobody now rates it at all. But of course, actually Apollo was a terrifying god. Why terrifying? Well, he's the god of plague for starters. Okay, that is terrifying. So having gone through the past year, it's Apollo's plague arrows god why terrifying why do you think well he's the god of plague for starters so that is today having gone through the past year um it's it's apollo's plague arrows that have been raining down on us um you know that's what the iliad begins with is is apollo raining down plague
而现在没有人看得起它了。但当然，实际上阿波罗是一位令人毛骨悚然的神。为什么令人毛骨悚然？好吧，首先他是瘟疫之神。好吧，这确实令人毛骨悚然。所以经历过去这一年，是阿波罗的瘟疫之箭……神，为什么令人毛骨悚然？你觉得为什么？好吧，首先他是瘟疫之神，所以这就是今天……在经历过去这一年之后，呃，是阿波罗的瘟疫之箭一直在向我们倾泻而下，呃，你知道的，《伊利亚特》开篇讲述的就是阿波罗向希腊军营倾泻瘟疫之箭……
arrows on the on the greek camp um he's also that you know he's the father of sclapius he's the god of healing so again you get that kind of weird tension that we see again through you know in all these gods um and he's the god of um of prophecy yeah um but you know again we talked about this before the way so he's one of his um epithets is loxias which is kind of the oblique god um so anything he tells you is likely to trick you that's a sloppy-ish element to him no because I think it's not setting out to deceive you it's factored in it's kind of like a crossword puzzle
箭……他也是——你知道的，他是阿斯克勒庇俄斯的父亲，他是医治之神——所以你再次看到了那种我们在所有这些神明身上都能看到的奇异张力；而且他是预言之神，呃……但是，你知道的，我们之前讨论过这一点，他的一个称号是“洛克西亚斯”，这是一种隐晦的神明的含义；所以他告诉你任何事情都可能会欺骗你。这其中有阿斯克勒庇俄斯式的元素吗？不，因为我认为这并不是故意要欺骗你，这已经被考虑进去了，它有点像一则填字游戏。
and the Greeks were puzzled by the people who had other oracles that when they got their oracles they just took them you know they just took them straight whereas the greeks knew that apollo's comments utterances yeah had to be read quite carefully and if you didn't get them properly then you'd probably come a cropper and this is the oracle of delphi so does the apollo cult begin at delphi or does delphi just adopt him well there's two there are two great cult. There's Delphi is one and Delos is the other. And Delos is where Apollo and his twin sister, the equally terrifying Artemis,
而希腊人对那些拥有其他神谕的人感到困惑，当他们得到神谕时，他们只是照单全收，你知道的，他们只是直接接受了；而希腊人则知道阿波罗的评论和言论需要仔细解读，如果你没有正确理解它们，你可能会栽大跟头。这就是德尔斐神谕。那么阿波罗的崇拜是从德尔斐开始的，还是德尔斐只是接纳了他？好吧，有两个伟大的崇拜中心。一个是德尔斐，另一个是提洛岛。提洛岛是阿波罗和他的孪生姐姐——同样令人毛骨悚然的处女猎神阿尔忒弥斯——出生的地方。
the Virgin Huntress, are born. And it's said that Delos was kind of floating around and then it gets anchored when they're born. And the thing that's interesting about both Delos and Delphi is that they're effectively neutral. So that's something that you don't get with other Greek gods. So it's not associated with a particular power, but a city state. Yeah. So both of those, they almost have a kind of missionary quality that's very exceptional in the Greek context.
据说提洛岛原本四处漂浮，直到他们出生时才被锚定。关于提洛岛和德尔斐，有趣的是它们实际上是中立的。所以这是你在其他希腊神明身上看不到的特点。所以它不与某个特定的权势或城邦相关联。是的。因此，这两者几乎都带有一种在希腊语境中非常罕见的传教性质。
And it means that both Delphi and Delos become neutral spaces where people from different cities can meet up. But as you say, Apollo, I think for that reason, becomes the archetype of the Greek god because he's, you know, he's with Zeus. He's kind of a properly universal one. But then the weird thing is that he's, you know, the epitome of the Greek god, but in the Trojan War in the Iliad, he's on the side of the Trojans, not the Greeks.
这意味着德尔斐和提洛岛都成为了中立空间，来自不同城市的民众可以在此相聚。但正如你所说，出于这个原因，阿波罗成为了希腊神明的原型，因为他与宙斯在一起。他可以说是一个名副其实的普遍神明。但诡异的是，尽管他是希腊神明的缩影，但在《伊利亚特》的特洛伊战争中，他却站在特洛伊人一边，而不是希腊人一边。
What's all that about? Because the Trojans in the Iliad are seen as basically belonging to the same world as the Greeks. Because they're part of the Greek world and he just happens to be on their side rather than the Achaeans or whatever they're called. Yeah. I mean, talking of the Trojan War, of course, there's a terrible warning there about picking gods and crowning one as the victor. Because that's what basically starts the whole shebang. Let's hope that um yes that doesn't one more question about apollo oh yeah um he has this habit of pursuing people who then
这到底是怎么回事？因为《伊利亚特》中的特洛伊人被视为基本上属于与希腊人相同的世界。因为他们是希腊世界的一部分，而他恰好站在他们这一边，而不是亚该亚人或无论他们叫什么的人。是的。说到特洛伊战争，当然，那里有一个可怕的警告：关于挑选神明并将其中一位加冕为胜利者。因为这基本上就是挑起整个事件的导火索。让我们希望……是的，不要……关于阿波罗还有一个问题。哦，是的……他有一种习惯，总是去追求那些后来变成植物的人，不是吗？风信子。他确实如此，他确实有。好吧，所以我们有——我们请来了无可匹敌的乔纳森·威尔逊提供轰动性的专家评论，但我们在半决赛中也有来自伟大的奥维德学者卢万·摩根的解说，他那本关于奥维德的简明导读真的非常棒，极力推荐。他在书中指出，我们认为的许多希腊神话实际上是奥维德神话，因为伟大的罗马诗人奥维德将这些故事打包成了一个单一的实体。他痴迷于人们改变形态，并为此写了整首诗，呃，是的，阿波罗追求的所有宁芙仙女，她们都变成了月桂树或诸如此类的东西，这绝对是一个常态。
turn into plants isn't that right hyacinth he does yes he does well so we had um one of the we had the um peerless jonathan wilson doing providing sensational punditry but we also had in the semifinals we had commentary from Llewellyn Morgan, the great Ovidian scholar, whose short introduction to Ovid is really fantastic, highly recommended. And he makes the point in that, that a lot of what we think of
变成植物，不是吗，风信子？他确实是，是的。嗯，所以我们有，嗯，其中一个，我们有，嗯，无与伦比的乔纳森·威尔逊提供精彩的球评，但我们在半决赛中也有卢埃林·摩根的解说，他是伟大的奥维德学者，他对奥维德的简短介绍真的非常棒，强烈推荐。他在其中指出，我们所认为的很多
as being Greek mythology is actually Ovidian mythology, because Ovid, the great Roman poet, takes these stories and packages them as a kind of single entity. And he's obsessed with people changing form and he writes his whole poem about it um and uh yes all the nymphs that apollo is changing they're kind of turning into laurel trees or whatever um that's that's
但这些基本上都源自奥维德，并由此对后世产生了巨大的影响。
absolutely a constant um but that's basically coming from ovid and from that it then passes into obviously huge influence on so So the Greek Apollo is not he's not molesting all these people who become trees. Well he kind of is, I mean there are these stories but it gets packaged in a way that then gets taken out around the world by Ovid
所以希腊的阿波罗并不是——他并没有骚扰所有这些变成树的人。好吧，他某种程度上确实有，我的意思是，这些故事确实存在，但它们经过包装，随后由奥维德带向了全世界。
so it's kind of like the Beatles absorbing all these various traditions and packaging them in a way that people can consume okay uh the beatles have made their um long expected appearance on the podcast about ancient gods and on that note card is filling up yeah on that note we'll take a break and we will come back to discuss the four semi-finalists after the break i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment after the break. to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
所以这有点像披头士乐队吸收了所有这些不同的传统，并将它们打包成人们能够消费的形式。好吧，呃，披头士乐队已经在关于古代神明的播客中万众期待地出场了。伴随着这个话题，卡片快写满了。是的，伴随着这个话题，我们稍作休息，中场休息后我们将回来讨论四强选手。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《一切皆娱乐》。中场休息结束后。若要购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We've now reached the semi-final stage of the World Cup of Gods. There are four contenders left and they are Dionysus, Isis, Athena and and Odin. So, Tom, let's do the two gods who would have ended up in the third, fourth place playoff, the bronze medal match that nobody ever wants to play in. And they are Dionysus, lost comfortably to Athena. Dionysus is a very interesting god, isn't he? So he's the son of Zeus and Persephone, is that right? Simile. Simile. I think there are different accounts with all these gods
欢迎回到《历史的本质》。我们现在来到了众神世界杯的半决赛阶段。还剩下四位竞争者，他们是狄奥尼索斯、伊西丝、雅典娜和奥丁。所以，汤姆，我们来聊聊那两位本应进入三四名决赛的神明——那场谁都不想踢的铜牌争夺战。他们是狄奥尼索斯，他轻松输给了雅典娜。狄奥尼索斯是一个非常有趣的神，对吧？所以他是宙斯和珀耳塞福涅的儿子，是这样吗？塞墨勒。塞墨勒。我想关于所有这些神明，有着不同的说法。
um often of their origins he's the god of wine he's the god of theater um and of course associated with the dionysian mysteries and with the bacchus cult in rome so again is bacch Bacchus and Dionysus, are they the same? Yeah. And the Bacchantes are people who follow Dionysus in kind of ecstatic rituals, and is the theme of Euripides' great play, The Bacchae, which describes how Dionysus comes to Thebes, and the king of Thebes tries to basically
呃，通常关于他们的起源。他是酒神，他是戏剧之神，当然，他还与狄奥尼索斯秘仪以及罗马的巴克科斯崇拜有关。所以同样地，巴克科斯和狄奥尼索斯是同一个人吗？是的。而巴克科斯的女祭司们是在狂喜仪式中追随狄奥尼索斯的人，这也是欧里庇得斯伟大的戏剧《巴克科斯女祭司》的主题，该剧描述了狄奥尼索斯如何来到忒拜，而忒拜国王试图将其驱逐。所以这有点像——我想——警察试图阻止狂欢者在田野里开狂欢派对一样。但是，呃，狄奥尼索斯可不吃这一套，呃，他伪装成女人——所以狄奥尼索斯的追随者迈纳德斯是一群被附身、极其暴力且处于狂喜状态的女性。因此，忒拜国王彭透斯伪装成迈纳德斯前去查看。但他被发现了，结果被自己的母亲撕成了碎片。
chase him off. So it's kind of like, I suppose, the police trying to stop you know ravers having raves in fields um but uh dionysus isn't having any of that and um he he goes disguised as a woman so he dionysus's followers the maenads are are women who get possessed and incredibly violent and ecstatic. And so Pentheus, the King of Thebes, goes there disguised as a Maenad. But he gets discovered and his own mother tears him to pieces.
把她赶跑。所以这有点像，我想，警察试图阻止那些狂欢者在田野里开狂欢派对，但狄奥尼索斯可不吃这一套，嗯，他伪装成女人，所以狄奥尼索斯的追随者，那些迈那德女祭司，都是些被附身、极其暴力且狂喜的女性。因此，底比斯国王彭透斯伪装成迈那德女祭司去那里。但他被发现了，甚至被自己的母亲撕成了碎片。
And that teaches him to try and stop people having a drunken orgy. So in the public mind, Dionysus is the god of drunken orgies. Is there more to him than that, do you think? Well, I don't know if you've read Roberto Colasso's Marriage of Cadmus and Harmony. I have not. Which is a wonderful book about the Greek gods. Very inimitable. And my favourite sentence in that book is as follows.
这给他上了一课，让他知道不要试图阻止人们举办酒神狂欢。所以在公众心目中，狄奥尼索斯是酒神狂欢之神。你认为他还有更深层的一面吗？好吧，我不知道你有没有读过罗伯托·卡拉索的《卡德摩斯与哈耳摩尼亚的婚礼》。我没有读过。这是一本关于希腊神明的奇妙书籍。非常独特。而我在那本书中最喜欢的一句话是这样的：
Dionysus's phallus is more hallucinogenic than coercive okay um so talk me through that well he he's he's he's a very erotic god yeah um he uh the Scythianians we're told worshipped him as lord of the female sex so he um it's said that he's the one whose fingers can can make it vibrate like the strings of a lyre so that is one of his one of his superpowers yeah um but the other superpower obviously is that um he can bring his followers into a kind of ecstatic altered state. So you get sexual fulfillment, but you also kind of leave the diurnal tedium of your everyday life behind and enter this kind of ecstasy state.
狄奥尼索斯的阴茎比强制力更具致幻性。好吧，呃，给我解释一下。嗯，他是一个非常色情的神，是的。呃，据我们所知，斯基泰人将他尊为女性之主的守护神，所以他——据说他的手指能让它像里拉琴的琴弦一样振动。所以这是他的超能力之一，是的。呃，但另一个超能力显然是，呃，他能将他的追随者带入一种狂喜的变性状态。所以你不仅能获得性满足，还能将日常生活中日复一日的沉闷抛在脑后，进入这种狂喜的状态。
But isn't there something, as the Euripides story suggests, something that's a kind of a more sinister side to this. I mean, weren't people alarmed even at the time about that sort of Dionysian cult and the Dionysian mysteries? The Romans ban it. They regard it as sinister and dangerous. And obviously there's a strong element of that
但是，正如欧里庇得斯的故事所暗示的那样，这里面难道没有某种更阴暗的一面吗？我的意思是，当时人们难道不就对那种狄奥尼索斯崇拜和狄奥尼索斯秘仪感到惊恐吗？罗马人禁止了它。他们认为这是险恶且危险的。显而易见，欧里庇得斯的作品中也有很强的这种成分。
in Euripides as well. But there's also a sense that Dionysus represents aspects of human character that it is folly to repress. Right. So the id, his pure id, basically. And that's what underpins Nietzsche's famous essay on the birth of tragedy, where he counterpoints Dionysus with Apollo as the kind of the yin and yang of Greek culture. Another very interesting aspect of Dionysus is that the story goes that he originally comes from India and he comes with a kind of great invasion force.
但在某种意义上，狄奥尼索斯也代表了人性中压抑即是愚蠢的那些方面。没错。所以说，他是纯粹的“本我”。而这正是尼采关于悲剧诞生的著名论著的基础，在书中他将狄奥尼索斯与阿波罗进行对比，将其视为希腊文化的阴与阳。狄奥尼索斯另一个非常有趣的方面是，传说他最初来自印度，并伴随着一支庞大的入侵军队来到这里。
Not soldiers, but, you know, girls in leopard skins and satyrs with vine leaves and things like that. But he brings elephants. And it was said that lots of these elephants died on the battle of of on the island of semos in in the um eastern aegean and what's interesting is that the skeletons of pleistocene um mastodons have been found there that's interesting and so adrian may, who's written a wonderful book about kind of classical paleontology, says that it's the first example that she can think of Macedon goes east to India, the Macedonians find places where Dionysus is worshipped. And they think that Dionysus has climbed these rocks
不是士兵，而是身穿豹皮的少女、头戴葡萄藤叶的萨提尔诸如此类的人物。但他带来了大象。据说其中许多大象死在了东爱琴海萨莫斯岛上的战役中。有趣的是，那里的确发现了更新世乳齿象的骨骼。这很有趣。因此，写过一本关于古典古生物学精彩著作的阿德里安·迈尔说，这是她能想到的第一个例子：马其顿人向东走向印度，马其顿人在那里发现了人们崇拜狄奥尼索斯的地点。他们认为狄奥尼索斯曾攀登过这些岩石，以及诸如此类的事情。因此，希腊世界显然有一种感觉，认为狄奥尼索斯与更东边发生的事情有着某种联系。在某些狄奥尼索斯的故事中，狄奥尼索斯被杀害并复活。一些学者说，好吧，这——你知道的，他是与同样被杀害并复活的欧西里斯保持某种延续性的一部分，当然，还有耶稣，他们都是同一个故事。你相信这种说法吗？还有，他的母亲被焚烧了，因为她被诱骗要求宙斯展现其全部荣耀。她整个人都萎缩了，而宙斯救了当时还是子宫里的小婴儿的狄奥尼索斯，并把它植入了自己的大腿中。
and all this sort of thing. So there is clearly a sense in the Greek world that Dionysus has something to do with things that are going on further east. There are some Dionysus stories in which Dionysus is killed and reborn. And some scholars have said, well, this, you know, he's part of a kind of continuum with Osiris,
诸如此类的事情。因此，在希腊世界中，显然有一种感觉，认为狄奥尼索斯与更东方发生的事情有关。有些关于狄奥尼索斯的传说中，狄奥尼索斯被杀并复活。一些学者说，嗯，这个，你知道，他是与奥西里斯相连的某种连续体的一部分，
who's also killed and reborn. And of course, Jesus, who's the same story. Do you buy that? Also, his mother gets incinerated because she gets tricked into asking Zeus to reveal himself in his full glory. And she gets kind of shriveled up and Zeus rescues Dionysus, whose little baby in the womb and implants it in his own thigh.
奥西里斯也是被杀并复活的。当然还有耶稣，也是同样的故事。你买账吗？此外，他的母亲被烧成灰烬，因为她被诱骗要求宙斯以其全部荣耀显现。她有点萎缩了，而宙斯救了狄奥尼索斯，当时他还是子宫里的小婴儿，并把他植入了自己的大腿中。
So that's, that's another kind of weird unusual. Do you know about Dionysus' association with Scotland? No. So in 1282, and that's in Viquething, the local vicar organised a Dionysian revel. Did he?
所以这也是另一种奇怪、不寻常的神。你知道狄奥尼索斯和苏格兰有什么渊源吗？不知道。所以在1282年，在维克辛，当地的牧师组织了一场狄奥尼索斯式的狂欢。是吗？
He persuaded the women of the village to join him in a Dionysian rite or some such. And what happened? A Christian mob killed him. Right. Well, fair enough. I mean, I think you're asking for trouble if you... 13th century Scotland holding Dionysian revels. I think, yeah, it's a risk, isn't it I mean, I think you're asking for trouble if you... 13th century Scotland holding Dionysian revels. I think, yeah, it's a risk, isn't it?
他劝说村里的妇女和他一起参加狄奥尼索斯式的仪式诸如此类的活动。然后发生了什么？一群基督徒暴徒杀了他。好吧，也是情理之中。我的意思是，我觉得如果你……在13世纪的苏格兰举行狄奥尼索斯式的狂欢，就是在自找麻烦。我觉得，是的，这是一种冒险，对吧？我的意思是，我觉得如果你……在13世纪的苏格兰举行狄奥尼索斯式的狂欢，就是在自找麻烦。我觉得，是的，这是一种冒险，对吧？
It's a bit cold apart for anything else. Yeah, it's true. So anyway, Dionysius, that wasn't enough. The Scottish vote wasn't enough to get him over the line. In fact, he lost very comfortably in the end. And so that was the end of him. And the other semi-final loser to your great sorrow, I imagine, given your stated position, was Isis.
抛开别的不谈，天气确实有点冷。是的，确实如此。所以无论如何，狄奥尼索斯，这还不够。苏格兰的选票不足以让他过关。事实上，他最后输得很轻松。所以这就是他的结局。至于另一个半决赛的失败者，根据你一贯的立场，我想你一定感到非常遗憾，那就是伊西斯。
No, I was fine. I just wanted to your stated position, was Isis. No, I was fine. I just wanted to see her get to semis. Isis is a very, very interesting god, isn't she? She's a massive god. She's a god who's part of this Egyptian kind of pantheon, as it were. They call it a pantheon. She's the wife of Osiris and the mother of Horus. But as time goes on, she becomes bigger and bigger.
不，我挺好的。我只是想——你一贯的立场是伊西斯。不，我挺好的。我只是想看她进半决赛。伊西斯是一个非常非常有趣的神，对吧？她是一个重量级神明。她是属于埃及神系的那种神，姑且这么说吧。他们称之为神系。她是欧西里斯的妻子，荷鲁斯的母亲。但随着时间的推移，她变得越来越伟大。
She becomes a sort of Apple computers or a Microsoft of gods. She's a startup that has just become imperial. So that by the end of the sort of ancient, the Ptolemaic period, she is one of the Mediterranean's absolute, you know, she's the Coke or the Levi's. She's a colossal brand, isn't she? She is. And she appears all over the Roman Empire. absolute you know she's the coke or the levi's she's a colossal brand isn't she she is and she appears all over the roman empire um and there's a kind of ecstatic account in um the golden ass
她有点像神明中的苹果公司或微软。她是一个刚刚走向帝国的初创公司。所以在古代、托勒密王朝的末期，她绝对是地中海地区的大腕，你知道的，她就像可口可乐或李维斯。她是一个庞大的品牌，对吧？确实如此。而且她出现在罗马帝国的各个角落。你知道的，她就像可口可乐或李维斯。她是一个庞大的品牌，对吧？确实如此。而且她出现在罗马帝国的各个角落，嗯，在《金驴记》中有一种非常狂喜的描述
by pulius which is the the only kind of surviving la roman novel in its entirety and this is sky lucius who gets turned into an ass uh and that's what he does throughout the course of the novel. And then at the end, he prays to Isis and she turns him back into his human shape. And he then goes on to become a massive devotee of Isis. And he shaves his head and is absolutely proud to go around bald. And then at the end, he has another vision of isis um and although we're not given the full details of this because this is a secret that you you can't reveal it it's it's a literally a mystery um nevertheless it's it's fascinating because it's one of the very very i think maybe even the only one really
作者是阿普列尤斯，这也是唯一一部完整保存下来的拉丁罗马小说。这是一个名叫卢修斯的家伙，他变成了一头驴，呃，这就是他在小说整个过程中的经历。然后在最后，他向伊西斯祈祷，她把他变回了人类的形状。然后他继续成为了伊西斯的一个狂热信徒。他剃光了头，光着头到处走也觉得无比自豪。然后到了最后，他又对伊西斯有了一次幻视，呃，虽然我们没有得到这方面的全部细节，因为这是一个秘密，你不能透露，它字面意义上就是一个神秘仪式，尽管如此，它还是非常迷人，因为它是极少数——我想甚至可能是唯一的一个——
that gives you a sense of kind of the ecstatic sense of identification that a worshipper of a god in the Roman period was capable of feeling. So it's a counterpoint to the sense of cults as being purely civic and transactional yeah um and and i think that um the story that we get that we get told about isis and the reason why isis and osiris and anubis and seth and all those guys kind of do have a cut through in a way that perhaps other egyptian gods don't is that it gets told by plutarch the um greek writer of the second century a.d uh and and he basically gives it to us as the equivalent of a kind of Greek myth. And so he gives us this story
能让你感受到那种狂喜的认同感，而这种认同感是罗马时期的神明崇拜者所能感受到的。所以，这与那种认为异教崇拜纯粹是公民和交易性质的观点形成了一种对立，嗯，并且我认为，我们听到的关于伊西斯的故事，以及为什么伊西斯、欧西里斯、阿努比斯、赛特和所有这些家伙能够产生共鸣，某种程度上是其他埃及神明可能无法比拟的，是因为它是通过普鲁塔克讲述给我们的，他是公元二世纪的希腊作家，呃，他基本上把它作为希腊神话的等价物讲给我们听。所以他给我们讲了这个故事
about how Isis is married to Osiris. Osiris's brother, Seth, kills Osiris. Anubis then embalms him. Seth sends the coffin that he's been put into flowing down the Nile, ends up in Phoenicia. Demeter goes and sources it, rescues Osiris, brings him back to life fleetingly, has sex with him. Osiris gets her pregnant with Horus before going off to become Lord of the Underworld.
关于伊西斯如何嫁给欧西里斯。欧西里斯的兄弟赛特杀死了欧西里斯。然后阿努比斯为他制作木乃伊。赛特把装有他的棺材顺着尼罗河漂流，最终到了腓尼基。德墨忒尔去寻找它，拯救了欧西里斯，让他短暂地复活，并与他发生性关系。欧西里斯让德墨忒尔怀上了荷鲁斯，然后去成为冥界之主。
Horus grows up and then kind of chases Seth away. And that's a story like we get in greek mythology well you and by and large we don't get that kind of stuff otherwise in egyptian mythology which is why i think it has less resonance with people than say greek myths you made a slip there which i thought was really revealing which is why i didn't correct it because it's really interesting you called called her Demeter. Ah, did I? And Isis and Demeter have been identified as similar, haven't they? I mean, they play a similar part. Well, so what happens when Isis goes to source the tomb of Osiris is that she pretends to be a nursemaid for the prince of, where is it?
荷鲁斯长大后便把赛特赶走了。这就像我们在希腊神话中听到的故事一样，而我们在埃及神话中通常听不到这种故事，这就是为什么我认为它比方说希腊神话更能引起人们的共鸣。你在那里说漏嘴了，我觉得这非常有启发性，所以我没有纠正你，因为真的很有趣，你把她叫做德墨忒尔。啊，我有吗？伊西斯和德墨忒尔被认为是相似的，对吧？我的意思是，她们扮演着相似的角色。嗯，所以当伊西斯去寻找欧西里斯的坟墓时，她假装成一个王子家里的保姆，那是哪里的王子？
I think it's Byblos or Tyre, one of them. And she wants to give the son of the Prince of Tyre immortality. And so she prepares him and is going to put him in the fire. And she's surprised doing this. So she has to reveal who she is. And a very similar story is told of Demeter
我想是比布罗斯或推罗，其中一个。她想给推罗王子的儿子永生。所以她为他做准备，打算把他放进火里。结果她做这件事时被发现了。所以她不得不透露自己的真实身份。而关于德墨忒尔也有一个非常相似的故事
at the time when she's roaming the world looking for her daughter, Persephone, who's been abducted by Hades, the god of the dead, and taken to the underworld. So do you think the Demeter cult is basically the Greeks? Because the Isis cult is obviously older.
当时她正在世界各地游荡，寻找她的女儿珀耳塞福涅，珀耳塞福涅被死神哈迪斯绑架并带到了地下世界。所以你认为德墨忒尔的崇拜基本上是希腊人的吗？因为伊西斯崇拜明显更古老。
Have the Greeks, probably through merchants or whatever, picked up the Isis cult? Do you think? Very difficult to know. And the Greeks themselves weren't sure. So there are lots of theories about that. The relationship of the Greek gods
希腊人是通过商人还是其他什么途径接受了伊西斯崇拜？你觉得呢？这很难说。希腊人自己也不确定。所以关于这一点有很多理论。希腊神明与埃及神明的关系
to the um to the egyptian gods so herodotus who's the first person really to write about egyptian gods absolutely clear that uh the egyptian gods come first and the greek gods are kind of pale echoes of the egyptian gods whereas for us it you know it's often the other way around the greek gods are much more vivid in our imaginings. But that's because of their sources. It's not because they're more... So I don't know is the answer. Maybe there's a kind of direct influence. But I think also it's the fact that people in antiquity
呃，比如希罗多德，他是第一个真正书写埃及神明的人，他非常清楚地表明，埃及神明是先出现的，而希腊神明只是埃及神明苍白的迴响，但在我们看来，情况往往恰恰相反，希腊神明在我们的想象中要生动得多。但这归因于他们的资料来源。并不是因为他们更……所以答案是我不知道。也许存在某种直接的影响。但我认为这也是因为古代的人们
are prone to accepting that everyone essentially is worshipping the same kind of gods. It's just that they manifest themselves in different ways. They're more ecumenical, weirdly, than we are. Yeah. And so, therefore, if you're a Greek going to Egypt, you're going to identify, say, Amun or Ra with Zeus. You're going to identify Isis with Demeter,
倾向于接受这样一种观点：本质上每个人崇拜的都是同一种神。只是它们以不同的方式显现出来。奇怪的是，他们比我们要包容得多。是的。所以，如果你是一个去埃及的希腊人，你会把阿蒙或拉等同于宙斯。你会把伊西斯等同于德墨忒尔，
rather like the Romans do as well. Well, then there's this period, isn't there, Tom, which is fascinating, which we haven't massively talked about, of pure sort of syncretism, when the Greeks are running Egypt. So when the Ptolemaic family, these Macedonian Greeks are running Egypt, and then they actually go out of their
就像罗马人所做的那样。那么，汤姆，接下来有一个时期非常迷人，我们之前没有怎么深入探讨过，那就是纯粹的融合时期，当时希腊人统治着埃及。所以当托勒密家族，这些马其顿希腊人统治埃及的时候，他们实际上在政治上刻意
way politically to identify Greek gods and Egyptian gods, because it obviously suits them, it suits their sort of empire building project. And they invent one, Serapis. Yes. Who we were thinking perhaps should have been included, but wasn't. But I mean, he's completely made up,
将希腊神明和埃及神明等同起来，因为这显然符合他们的利益，符合他们的帝国建设大业。他们发明了一位神，塞拉皮斯。是的。我们曾考虑过也许应该把他包括在内，但最终没有。不过我的意思是，他是完全凭空捏造出来的，
kind of fusion of Greek and Egyptian elements. But that raises a really interesting question, doesn't it? That again, a bit like we were talking about Augustus on the last podcast and about how including him sort of, it changes the way you think about the division between mortal and immortal the sort of slightly simplistic way that we might think of it today i mean clearly they don't think there's anything wrong with inventing a god i think i think we bring a you know and i've said this before i'll say it again but we bring a christian perspective
可以说是希腊和埃及元素的融合。但这引发了一个非常有趣的问题，不是吗？就像我们上期播客讨论奥古斯都时所说的那样，包括他在内某种程度上改变了你对凡人与不朽之间界限的看法，也就是我们今天可能持有的一种略显简单的看法。我的意思是，很明显他们觉得发明一个神并没有什么不对，我想——我想我们带着——而且我以前说过，我还要再说一遍——我们带着一种基督教的视角，
and we find it very imagined you would say that. The very idea of kind of gathering all these together as pagan gods is a Christian perspective. And in the last podcast, we talked about the way in which gods become dead. Christianity is like a kind of radiation leak killing them off. Yeah. And Islam. And we see them through that prism, I think.
并且我们觉得这很难想象你会这么说。把所有这些统称为异教神明的这种想法本身就是一种基督教视角。在上期播客中，我们讨论了神明消亡的方式。基督教就像一场辐射泄漏，把它们赶尽杀绝。还有伊斯兰教。我认为我们正是通过这种棱镜来看待它们的。
And one last thing about ISIS. So ISIS is very political because Cleopatra VII, the famous Cleopatra, she takes the title, the new ISIS, and she dresses up as ISIS. And this is all part of claiming her legitimacy, but it's also linking herself
关于伊西斯的最后一件事。伊西斯具有非常浓厚的政治色彩，因为克娄巴特拉七世，也就是著名的克娄巴特拉，她给自己取了“新伊西斯”的称号，并且她将自己打扮成伊西斯的模样。这都是她宣示合法性的一部分，同时也是为了将自己
to this incredibly successful cult. And Octavian Augustustus who we talked about in the last podcast um he tries to to sort of keep this out of his self as apollo does he i didn't know that yeah so anthony had identified himself with dynisis yes uh octavian identifies himself with apollo and and cleopatra is going the full isis but then when he wins he says, let's not have any Isis temples in Rome. And the Senate is very hostile to the Isis cult. Is that because it's seen as too Egyptian? It's sort of orientalizing. Yeah, but it's there.
与这个极其成功的崇拜联系起来。我们在上期播客中讨论过的屋大维·奥古斯都，他试图将这一点排除在自我形象之外，阿波罗也是如此，是吗？我不知道这一点。是的，安东尼把自己等同于狄奥尼索斯，是的，屋大维把自己等同于阿波罗，而克娄巴特拉则完全扮演伊西斯，但当屋大维获胜后，他说，罗马不允许有任何伊西斯神庙。元老院对伊西斯崇拜非常敌视。这是因为它被视为太埃及化了吗？这有点东方化色彩。是的，但它确实存在。
I mean, by the end of, say, by 69 AD, the year of the four emperors after Nero, there are priests of Isis everywhere and they get embroiled in a kind of punch up that ends up with the incineration of the Temple of Jupiter on the Capitol. So they're absolutely a part of it. And actually, the worship of Isis
我的意思是，到比如公元69年，也就是尼禄之后四个皇帝的那一年，伊西斯神庙的祭司到处都是，他们卷入了一场混战，最终导致卡皮托利山上朱庇特神庙被焚毁。所以他们绝对是其中的一部分。事实上，对伊西斯的崇拜
carries on into the reign of Justinian, the great Christian emperor of the 6th century who builds Hagia Sophia in Constantinople. There's a temple to Isis at Philae, which is kind of right at the bottom of the south century who builds Hagia Sophia in Constantinople, there's a temple to Isis at Philae, which is kind of right at the bottom of the south of Egypt, an island in the Nile, that's only closed then. So she goes on a very long way. Very long time.
一直持续到查士丁尼统治时期，他是6世纪伟大的基督教皇帝，在君士坦丁堡建造了圣索菲亚大教堂。在菲莱有一座伊西斯神庙，它位于埃及南部最底端的尼罗河中的一个岛屿上，直到那时才关闭。所以她的影响力延续了非常漫长的时间。非常长的时间。
And what do you think of this argument among some comparative sort of scholars that the relationship between Isis and Horus is sort of paving the way for the relationship between Mary and Jesus I'm sure I mean I'm sure that that um there's you know if you're if you're having statues of of Isis suckling Horus um it's not a great leap then to yeah you know it's it's it's not that um Christians are kind of stealing it it It's just that it's the kind of the emotional fulfillment that you get, I guess, from identifying with Mary has been prefigured by the emotional identification
你如何看待某些比较学者的这种观点，即伊西斯和荷鲁斯之间的关系为玛丽和耶稣之间的关系铺平了道路？我确信，我的意思是，我确信，如果你有伊西斯给荷鲁斯哺乳的雕像，那么跨越到……这就不是一个巨大的跨越了。你知道的，这并不是说基督徒在窃取它，而是通过将自己等同于玛丽所获得的情感满足，已经通过一代又一代人
that generations and generations of people have had from looking at Isis. Yeah, and the idea, I suppose, is just there in the ether, isn't it, of the mother and child? I mean, it's just part of the cultural conversation. Okay, so Isis, I mean, there was a similar margin in the two semifinals. Isis also got knocked out. I think, frankly, she did well to make the semis.
在看着伊西斯时所获得的情感认同得到了预示。是的，而且这种母亲与孩子的概念，我想，本来就弥漫在空气中，不是吗？我的意思是，它只是文化对话的一部分。好吧，所以伊西斯，我的意思是，两场半决赛的比分差距很接近。伊西斯也被淘汰了。坦率地说，我认为她能进半决赛已经很棒了。
She's very interesting. She's an interesting god, though. I don't begrudge her her place in the last four. I think it was great, actually, to have somebody who, from out of the traditional sort of superpowers of Greece and the Norse world, and somebody who worshipped across the Mediterranean and stuff. So let's get to the final.
她非常有趣。不过她是一个有趣的神。我不嫉妒她占据了前四名的位置。实际上，我认为能有这样一位神真的很棒，她来自希腊和北欧世界的传统超级大国之外，是一位在整个地中海备受崇拜的神。那么让我们进入决赛吧。
Athena versus Odin. I think Athena was our number one seed. So we clearly always saw this coming. Odin, I think, I can't remember what, he was seeded about five or six, wasn't he? Who should we do first? Let's do Odin first and see, I can't remember what, he was seeded about 5 or 6, wasn't he? Who should we do first? Let's do Odin first. He was the runner-up.
雅典娜对阵奥丁。我认为雅典娜是我们的头号种子。所以我们显然早就预料到了这一点。奥丁，我想，我记不清了，他的种子排名大概是第五或第六，对吧？我们先讨论谁？我们先讨论奥丁，看看——我记不清了，他的种子排名大概是第五或第六，对吧？我们先讨论谁？先讨论奥丁吧。他获得了亚军。
So Odin was beaten. It was a very tight result. Exciting match. 52-48. Athena got off to an early lead. Odin ate into it, but not by enough. And it was 48-52. Yeah, I mean, very Romain leave.
所以奥丁战败了。这是一个非常胶着的结果。一场精彩的比赛。52比48。雅典娜开局领先。奥丁缩小了差距，但还不够。比分是48比52。是的，我的意思是，非常罗马式的离场。
But the roles reversed, because I think Odin had a bit of a lever kind of. Yeah, definitely. He's sort of, you know, he's all about plucking out his eye. Which they're all doing. Sunderland and the Brexit heart. Well, he's very red meat, isn't he, Odin? He certainly is, yeah. He's Woden or Wotan.
但角色对调了，因为我觉得奥丁有点像那种……是的，绝对的。他有点像那种，你知道的，他挖出了自己的眼球。他们都在做这件事。桑德兰和脱欧核心区。好吧，奥丁非常直白生猛，对吧？他当然是，是的。他是沃登或沃坦。
Tacitus. Didn't Tacitus equate him with Mercury, which seems very odd. Yeah. I mean, they're all over the place. I mean, yeah. So in his form as Woden, of course, he's given his name to Wednesday. Yeah. And he's the ancestor of the Queen.
塔西陀。塔西陀不是把他等同于墨丘利吗，这看起来很奇怪。是的。我的意思是，他们到处都是。我的意思是，是的。所以以沃登的身份，当然，他把自己的名字留给了星期三。是的。而且他是女王的祖先。
And he's the ancestor of the Queen. West Midlands. And the ancestor of the Wednesday. Yeah. And he's the ancestor of the Queen. And he's the ancestor of the Queen. West Midlands. And the ancestor of the Queen. Yeah. Who is descended from Woden then among the Queen's ancestors? The House of Wessex. Is it?
而且他是女王的祖先。西米德兰兹。还有星期三俱乐部的祖先。是的。而且他是女王的祖先。而且他是女王的祖先。西米德兰兹。而且他是女王的祖先。是的。那么在女王的祖先中，谁是沃登的后代？威塞克斯王室。是吗？
Yeah. So the Queen's, you know, trace her ancestry back to Alfred and Alfred can trace his ancestry back to Kurdic, who's the first of the Wessexan kings, supposedly. Yeah.
是的。所以女王的——你知道的，她的家谱可以追溯到阿尔弗雷德，而阿尔弗雷德的家谱可以追溯到库迪克，据说是威塞克斯的第一位国王。是的。
And he can trace his ancestry all the way back to Woden. So Prince Philip was, who got knocked out in the first round, king supposedly yeah and he can trace his ancestry all the way back to woden so prince philip was who got knocked out in the first round he did have family connections in the tournament which is nice well he married it he married the descendant of a goddess yeah that's that's good and that's one that's one of the reasons why i'd be sad personally to see the monarchy go is because i love the idea of having of being ruled by you know having a head of state who's descended from a god. Yeah. So not just a god's vicegerent on Earth, but the descendants of another god.
并且他的家谱可以一路追溯到沃登。所以菲利普亲王——他在第一轮就被淘汰了——据说也是国王的后代。是的，他的确和这次锦标赛有家族渊源，这挺好的。嗯，他娶了——他娶了一个女神的后代。是的，这挺好的，这也是为什么我个人看到君主制消亡会感到难过的原因之一，因为我喜欢这种由——由一个神明后代统治的国家，由一个拥有神明血统的国家元首统治的理念。是的。所以不仅仅是神在人间的代理人，而是另一个神明的后代。
So Macron calls himself Jupiter. Does he? But we know that he's a people. Does Macron call himself Jupiter? Yeah, he does. How do we know that? It's all over the place. Oh, my word.
所以马克龙称自己为朱庇特。是吗？但我们知道他是个普通人。马克龙真的称自己为朱庇特吗？是的，他确实这么叫过。我们怎么知道的？到处都是。天哪。
French. But our head of state is descended from a god. But Woden is quite boring oh my word French but we we have you know our head of state is descended from a god but Woden is quite boring because we don't really know anything about him
法语。但我们的国家元首是神明的后代。但沃登相当无趣——天哪，法语，但我们——你知道的，我们的国家元首是神明的后代，但沃登相当无趣，因为我们对他的了解实在不多
so hold on Odin so Odin and Woden it's the same thing but Odin is the name is the Viking name for him yeah and he's eye plucking out
所以等等，奥丁——所以奥丁和沃登是一回事，但奥丁是维京人对他的称呼，是的，他为了让自己变得更聪明而
to make himself wiser yeah he wounds himself with the spear it's very sort of fissure he hangs himself from a tree from It's very sort of Fisher King-ish. He hangs himself from a tree. An Yggdrasil.
挖出了自己的眼睛，是的，他用长矛刺伤自己，这非常具有某种“渔王”的色彩。他把自己挂在一棵树上，挂在世界之树上。
Is it Yggdrasil? Yeah, probably. Well, it's a rootless tree, and so people assume it is. And he hangs himself there for nine days, nine nights, and this wins him wisdom. Right, yes. And the other way he gets wisdom, yes, so the eye plucking. Yeah.
是世界之树吗？对，很可能是。嗯，这是一棵没有根的树，所以人们都以为它是。他在那里吊了九天九夜，这为他赢得了智慧。没错，是的。他获得智慧的另一种方式，是的，就是挖出眼睛。对。
So the well of Mimirir and he plucks out his eye and then is able to drink from the water so he absorbs this this um all this wisdom and then mime is who's a kind of giant spirit kind of guy has he he dies and so odin chops his head off and carries it around with him uh and consults the head of mime whenever he needs something so it's a bit like an iphone i guess it's a kind of oh you're always looking at your head a norse iphone yes yeah um and well that i mean okay so that's pretty gory and the sort of the the image that the the in the in the popular imagination is that the greek gods are all about kind of strumming lyres and drinking wine
也就是密米尔之泉，他挖出自己的眼珠，然后就能饮用泉水，从而吸收了这种，嗯，所有的智慧。接着密米尔——他是一个类似巨人的精灵似的人物——他死了，于是奥丁砍下他的头，带着它到处走，呃，每当需要的时候就去向密米尔的头请教，所以这感觉有点像iPhone，对吧？有点像，哦，你总是盯着自己的头看，北欧的iPhone，对，没错。呃，好吧，这——我的意思是，好吧，这相当血腥，而且在——大众想象中，那种印象是，希腊神祇无非就是弹奏竖琴、喝着葡萄酒
and sort of admiring grapes. Well, Odin, there's a brilliant line. On wine alone does weapon-glorious Odin live. On wine alone? Yeah, so that's... That's quite surprising. So he's not all about meat hauls and beer. I think he had that as well.
以及欣赏葡萄。嗯，奥丁，有一句绝妙的诗：唯有美酒，令战耀奥丁生存。唯有美酒？对，所以那是……这相当令人意外。所以他并非只关心肉宴和啤酒。我想他也有这些。
There's a more sophisticated side to him that we don't often see. But this is my question. In the public imagination, the life of the Vikings, the life of the northern peoples before the coming of Christianity was very nasty, brutish, and short. It's always raining, and they're always killing each other. And that, therefore, their gods are similarly violent, and their mythological world is similarly bleak,
他身上有一种我们不常见到的、更复杂的一面。但这是我的问题。在大众的想象中，维京人的生活，在基督教到来之前北方人民的生活是非常悲惨、残酷而短暂的。总是下雨，他们总是在互相残杀。因此，他们的神祇也同样暴力，他们的神话世界也同样阴暗，
in contrast to the more sort of loose ways of the Mediterranean gods. Do you think that's true? Or was that just a sort of silly stereotype? The classical gods are pretty terrifying, as I'm sure we'll talk about when we come to Athena. I mean, they kill a lot of people. I mean, basically, they start the Trojan War just because they're bored.
这与地中海神祇那种比较随意的生活方式形成了对比。你觉得这是真的吗？还是只是一种愚蠢的刻板印象？古典神祇其实相当吓人，就像我们讲到雅典娜时肯定会讨论的那样。我是说，他们杀了很多很多人。我的意思是，基本上，他们挑起特洛伊战争仅仅是因为他们无聊。
Yeah. There's a lot of death. But Odin is a very, yes mean i think he's you know he's the the lord of the valkyries who you know there's kind of terrifying descriptions of them um stretching out intestines across battlefields as though they're the threads on a loom i mean kind of terrifying images and odin himself um he so one of the other ways in which he he gets wisdom is to sit under under people who've been hanged so that's so he clearly absorbs wisdom from the experience of human suffering and you've just got to look at the list of names so there's a fabulous book by neil price i think it's called
对。有大量的死亡。但奥丁是一个非常，是的，我是说我认为他，你知道的，他是女武神的领主，你知道对她们有种可怕的描绘，嗯，把内脏像织布机上的经线一样拉伸在战场上，我的意思是，这是一种可怕的景象。而奥丁本人，嗯，他——他获得智慧的另一种途径是坐在被绞死的人下面，所以，这显然他是从人类苦难的经历中吸收智慧。你只要看看名字的清单就知道了——尼尔·普莱斯有一本极棒的书，我想它叫作
the viking way oh yes that's the predecessor to his children of ashnell it's really brilliant really really brilliant i and i read it in as a pdf before it's been properly published and and it was kind of like a samizdat work that people were handing around and he his argument is that this is all about kind of shamanism that you you have to get into a heightened state um And Odin, he lists all the names that Odin has been given in all the various epics and the runes and whatever. And there are over 200. So I noted down some of them.
《维京人的生活方式》（The Viking Way）。哦，对，那是他那本《灰烬之子》（Children of Ash and Elm）的前传，真的非常棒，非常非常棒。我以前在一份PDF上读过，在它正式出版之前，它有点像人们私下传阅的地下出版物。他的论点是，这一切都与萨满教有关，即你必须进入一种高度亢奋的状态，嗯。而奥丁——他列出了奥丁在各种史诗、如尼文以及其他地方被赋予的所有名字。有两百多个。所以我记下了其中一些。
You've got Father of the Slain, Lord of Treachery, Screamer, the Hooded One, Battle Wolf, Evil Worker, Lord of the Dead, Hangjaw,, nourisher of carrion eaters, lord of the hanged. Wow. I'd like some of them on my tombstone. That's not somebody you want to mess with. No, that's very impressive. And also he's got pets, hasn't he?
你有被戮者的父亲、背叛之主、尖叫者、戴兜帽者、战狼、恶行制造者、死者之主、吊下巴、食腐动物的滋养者、受绞者之主。哇。我真想把其中几个刻在我的墓碑上。那可不是你想招惹的人。不，这太令人印象深刻了。而且他还有宠物，对吧？
Well, he's got ravens. What else has he got? He's got two ravens who are both called Thord. He's got his eight-legged horse Sleipnir, and he's got two wolves, Freckie and brill brilliantly, Jerry. Jerry. If I had a wolf, I'd call him Jerry, I think. Actually, I think it's Gary, but it's funnier if it's Jerry.
嗯，他有乌鸦。他还养了什么？他有两只乌鸦，名字都叫索德（Thord）。他有一匹八足马斯雷普尼尔（Sleipnir），他还有两只狼，一只叫弗雷基（Freckie），妙极了，另一只叫杰瑞（Jerry）。杰瑞。如果我养了一只狼，我想我会叫它杰瑞。其实，我想它叫加里（Gary），但如果叫杰瑞就更搞笑了。
But he comes to a... I mean, none of that avails him much because he's eaten by a wolf himself. Yeah, Fenrir. Isn't he? Fenrir, yeah. So he comes to... The son of Loki. And this is, again, quite unusual in the Norse cosmology, isn't it?
但他迎来了……我的意思是，这些对他的帮助都不大，因为他自己被一只狼吃掉了。对，芬里尔。不是吗？芬里尔，对。所以他迎来了……洛基的儿子。在北欧宇宙观中，这又是不太寻常的，对吧？
Because we don't have a sense of how the Greek cosmos will end. But we do have that with the Norse gods, a sense of apocalypse, looming apocalypse. And there's no sense that for Apollo, it's all going to turn horribly nasty one day and come to a hideous end. Whereas for all the Norsese gods we know precisely what's going to happen to them and it's never very pleasant and you'd assume that that's an authentic tradition i mean the the complication is that the account of ragnarok you know the end of the gods got much later is written by a christian writer and so to what extent has this been mediated through Christian takes on the apocalypse
因为我们对希腊宇宙将如何终结并没有什么概念。但对于北欧神祇，我们确实有这种末日感，迫在眉睫的末日感。我们不觉得阿波罗有一天会变得极其糟糕并迎来一个可怕的结局。然而对于我们所知的所有的北欧神祇，我们精确地知道将会发生什么，而且从来都不怎么愉快。你会认为这是一个真实的传统——复杂之处在于，关于诸神黄昏（也就是诸神的结局）的记述要晚得多，是由一位基督教作家写下来的，那么这在多大程度上是通过基督教对末日的理解来进行调和的呢？
and the end of the world? And we don't know. And, but so Odin does, you know, like so many gods fades before the coming of Christianity. But there is, in Iceland, there are kind of charm formulas that continue to mention Odin right the way into the early modern period.
以及世界的终结？我们不得而知。但是，所以奥丁确实，你知道的，像许多神一样，在基督教到来之前逐渐消逝了。但在冰岛，有一些咒语公式一直延续到近代早期，其中仍然提到了奥丁。
And even in Sweden, there are kind of folk memories of him, not as a god, but as someone who I think if he appears, he will bring you wealth. He's a kind of devil, a demon. So he kind of leaves trace elements there. There's all the stuff about him leading the wild hunt as well, isn't there? Well, that's kind of more, yes, perhaps, but hugely contested. Right. So it may not be the same thing. It may not be the same Odin.
甚至在瑞典，也有关于他的民间记忆，不是作为神，而是作为一个我认为如果他出现就会带给你财富的人。他有点像魔鬼，一个恶魔。所以他留下了某种痕迹。关于他领导荒野狩猎（Wild Hunt）的那些传说也到处都是，对吧？嗯，那可能更多一些，是的，也许吧，但争议极 大。没错。所以这可能不是同一回事。可能不是同一个奥丁。
Yeah. So Odin essentially then gets reinvented in the 19th century. Yeah. And, of course, gets adopted by the Nazis. So he's very popular with neo-Nazis. I think the guy who wore the bison head who broke into the Capitol. He's done the Viking gods no favours.
对。所以奥丁基本上在19世纪被重新发酵了。是的。而且，当然，被纳粹收编了。所以他在新纳粹中非常受欢迎。我想那个戴着野牛头闯入国会大厦的家伙。他可没给维京神祇帮什么忙。
No, he hasn't. I think he had all kinds of Odin tattoos and stuff. Did he? He's the man who had, when he was imprisoned in Arizona or New Mexico or wherever it was, his mother made a great fuss and said he had to have vegan food.
不，他没有。我想他身上有各种奥丁的纹身之类的东西。是吗？就是那个当他被关在亚利桑那州或新墨西哥州或者什么地方的监狱里时，他母亲大惊小怪，说他必须吃纯素食的人。
Did you see that? Organic food. Right. Okay. Well, Odin wouldn't. No, he wouldn't. Well, anyway, Odin put up a very, very strong showing. He got 48% of the vote, but it wasn't enough because he was up against the number one seed, Mary Beard's choice before the tournament. Athena. Athena.
你看到了吗？有机食品。对。好吧，奥丁可不会。不，他不会。无论如何，奥丁表现得非常非常强劲。他获得了48%的选票，但这还不够，因为他的对手是头号种子——玛丽·比尔德（Mary Beard）在比赛前挑选的选手。雅典娜。雅典娜。
Athena won. I was a bit disappointed, Tom, if I can be quite. Why were you disappointed? I wanted Athena to win. Did you? She's my patron goddess. I didn't want Athena to win. I was a bit disappointed because I thought she was a bit of an obvious choice. You will be horrified by this because you're going to now tell me this is
雅典娜赢了。汤姆，说实话，我有点失望。你为什么失望？我希望雅典娜赢。是吗？她是我的守护女神。我不想让雅典娜赢。我有点失望，因为我觉得她有点像一个显而易见的选择。你会对此感到震惊，因为你接下来要告诉我，这是
completely a complete misreading. I find Athena a bit colourless. I am horrified. Yeah, to me, she's just a bit too mainstream. She's – I like a niche god. I like her kind of music. I like her – yeah, she's the Coldplay. She's Coldplay.
完全完全的误读。我觉得雅典娜有点苍白无力。我太震惊了。是的，对我来说，她有点太主流了。她——我喜欢小众的神。我喜欢她的那种音乐。我喜欢她——对，她是酷玩乐队（Coldplay）。她是酷玩乐队。
Yeah, you liked her before she – Before she was – I saw her when she was nothing. She's Coldplay. You liked her before she... I saw her when she was nothing. Before she became famous. I saw her at the Civic Hall in Northampton. She's the embodied... She's, again, a bit like Ishtar. She fuses warfare with the arts of civilisation. So she's wisdom and war.
对，你在她……之前就喜欢她。在她——我看到她时她什么都不是。她是酷玩乐队。你在她……之前就喜欢她。我看到她时她什么都不是。在她成名之前。我在北安普顿的市民大厅看过她的演出。她化身……她也是，有点像伊什塔尔（Ishtar）。她将战争与文明的艺术融合在一起。所以她是智慧与战争的结合体。
And war. And is it right? I'm thinking she takes her name from Athens rather than the other way around. Probably. She began as the civic goddess of Athens. Yeah, probably. We don't know. But yes, so she gives her name to Athens.
还有战争。我说得对吗？我想她是根据雅典娜的名字来命名的，而不是反过来。很可能。她最初是雅典娜城的城邦守护神。是的，很可能。我们不知道。但是，是的，所以她把自己的名字赐予了雅典娜城。
She's the patron of Athens. Her name is the same as athens um and she is the presiding genius of the golden age of the democracy and actually it it it's impossible to understand the significance of democracy without understanding the relationship that the athenians had with athena why because well she got to do with it so so what you'll hear about athenian democracy and it's always said is um it wasn't real democracy because only men you know free men had to vote what about the women um and what about the slaves the thing is that that athena is the is is the the guarantor of the um relationship that the Athenians have with their past and with their future. And the demos, the power that's vested in the demos, the demos is the totality of every Athenian
她是雅典娜城的守护神。她的名字与雅典娜相同，嗯，她也是民主黄金时代的庇护精灵。事实上，如果不理解雅典娜城人与雅典娜之间的关系，就不可能理解民主的重要性。为什么呢？嗯，这跟她有什么关系？所以，你会听到关于雅典娜城民主的说法，人们总说：嗯，这不是真正的民主，因为只有男性——你知道，自由男性——才能投票。女性怎么办？
that's lived and will live. And you have to have been born on the soil of Attica because that's sacred to Athena. So you can't be an Athenian if you're born elsewhere. You were literally born from the soil, you're Tocthonus. And therefore, it's as important to keep Athena on board as it is to sit in the assembly and draw up laws. So the role of men is to sit in the assembly and draw up laws. The role of women basically is to keep Athena happy. And for the Athenians, that's just as significant.
还有奴隶呢？问题在于，雅典娜是雅典娜城人与过去及未来之间关系的担保人。而人民（demos），即赋予人民的权力，这个“人民”包含了每一个曾经生活过和将要生活过的雅典娜城人的整体。你必须出生在阿提卡（Attica）的土地上，因为那是雅典娜的神圣领地。所以如果你出生在别处，你就不能成为雅典娜城人。你 literalmente（字面意义上）是从泥土中诞生的，你是大地之子（Autochthonous）。因此，让雅典娜站在我们这边，与坐在议会里起草法律同样重要。所以男性的角色是坐在议会里起草法律。女性的角色基本上就是让雅典娜保持高兴。对于雅典娜城人来说，这同样意义重大。
So female listeners who will say, well, that just sounds like typical men making up a reason to keep women sort of in their place, you'd say that's not true at all. That's actually... That's a very 21st century perspective. Yeah. And it's a perspective, again,
所以那些女性听众会说，这听起来不过是大男子主义者编造的借口，好把女性限制在她们的固有位置上。你会说这完全不是真的。这实际上……这是一种非常21世纪的视角。是的。这也是一种视角，
that ultimately comes from Christianity that says that every human being is of equal value and equal right. That's not how the Greeks saw it. The Greeks saw it in a very, very different way. So when we we assume we think of democracy as a kind of abstract principle that everyone should have a vote because everybody has an equal value. And therefore, if you're saying that women can't have the vote, then you're saying that women have are less, less valuable, that their opinions are less valuable, that their rights are less significant. For the Athenians, it's about keeping the demos on the road. And you do what you do to ensure that happens. So the men draw up the laws and they go off and fight to defend the demos. And the women have this relationship with Athena and they do the necessary rituals that will keep Athena on board, which likewise is just as important.
它最终源于基督教，即每个人都具有同等的价值和同等的权利。希腊人可不是这么看的。希腊人以一种非常非常不同的方式看待这个问题。因此，当我们认为民主是一种抽象原则——每个人都应该有一票，因为每个人的价值都是平等的。因此，如果你说女性不能投票，那么你就是在说女性低人一等，价值更低，她们的意见价值更低，她们的权利不那么重要。对于雅典娜城人来说，这是关于让人民（demos）的车轮继续转动。你做你该做的事，以确保这一点得以实现。因此，男人们起草法律，然后出发去战斗以保卫人民。而女性则与雅典娜保持这种关系，并进行必要的仪式，让雅典娜保持满意，这同样至关重要。
But it's so you've got to kind of put yourself into the shoes of someone for whom Athena is a powerful, terrifying, but ultimately wooable figure. Why terrifying, Tom? You've said that a few times. She kills a lot of people. Okay. I mean, the classic one is that anyone basically who calls her out, she kills or turns into spiders. So Arachne, the maiden who claims that she's better
但你必须设身处地去想象那样一个人：对他们而言，雅典娜是一个强大、可怕但最终可以取悦的人物。为什么可怕，汤姆？你已经说过好几次了。她杀了很多很多的人。好吧。我的意思是，最典型的例子是，基本上任何敢于挑战她的人，她都会杀死或把他们变成蜘蛛。比如阿拉克涅（Arachne），那个声称自己比雅典娜
at weaving than Athena. And Athena zaps her into a spider. And she's merciless to those who offend her equally. And this is why I think she's a great god and why I think that she corresponds to something kind of fundamental in the nature of the way that life is. You know, she has people she hates
更擅长织布的少女。结果雅典娜把她“滋”成了一只蜘蛛。她对那些冒犯她的人同样毫不留情。这就是为什么我认为她是一个伟大的神，为什么我认为她契合了某种生命本质中的根本东西。你知道，她有她讨厌的人，
and she has her favourites. And that seems true to life. There are people who have a kind of golden existence. And of course, her most famous favourite is Odysseus. Yes, because she's copped up again and again, doesn't she, in the Odyssey and also in the Iliad. She's very, very close to her protégés in a way that other gods aren't. Other gods are kind of more distant. But Athena is always at their ear, kind of whispering in them. There's a wonderful collection of short stories about the Odyssey called The Lost Books of the
也有她偏爱的人。这似乎很符合生活。有些人确实拥有黄金般的生存状态。当然，她最著名的宠儿是奥德修斯（Odysseus）。是的，因为她在《奥德赛》甚至《伊利亚特》中一次又一次地出现，不是吗？她与她的门徒非常非常亲近，这是其他神所不及的。其他神显得更疏离一些。但雅典娜总是贴在他们的耳边，对他们呢喃细语。有一部关于《奥德赛》的绝妙短篇小说集，叫作扎卡里·梅森（Zachary Mason）的《奥德赛的迷失之书》（The Lost Books of the Odyssey）。
Odyssey by Zachary Mason. And there's a great story in that where Athena is secretly in love with Odysseus. And she tells Odysseus that she's in love with him and Odysseus laughs and she then vanishes. She goes bright red and vanishes. Very effective. Nice. Highly recommended. She's a virgin, isn't she? She's a virgin, yes. And so do you think there's a link? We've talked a few times about this, about links with
其中有一个很棒的故事，讲的是雅典娜暗恋奥德修斯。她告诉奥德修斯她爱他，奥德修斯笑了，接着她就消失了。她脸涨得通红，然后消失了。非常戏剧化。不错。强烈推荐。她是个处女，对吧？她是个处女，是的。那么你认为这其中有什么联系吗？我们之前讨论过好几次，关于与
Christianity or with subsequent religions. Is there a link with the Virgin Mary, do you think there's a link? We've talked a few times about this, about links with Christianity or with subsequent religions. Is there a link with the Virgin Mary, do you think? Well, her shrine, the most famous shrine, Temple Parthenos, Parthenon, the Virgin, the kind of the Virgin's temple becomes the church dedicated to the Virgin in the Christian period. And what's what's also interesting is that um athena guards the walls of athens so when athens is is attacked she can be seen walking the walls patrolling it i know where you're gonna what you're gonna say constantinople so constantinople the virgin is seen yeah protecting constantinople when when when the city is under siege and that's a tradition that then passes into the folklore
基督教或后续宗教的联系。你认为这与圣母玛利亚有什么联系吗？我们之前讨论过好几次，关于与基督教或后续宗教的联系。你认为这与圣母玛利亚有什么联系吗？嗯，她的神殿，最著名的神殿——帕台农神庙（Temple Parthenos, Parthenon），处女神庙，这种处女的神殿在基督教时期变成了献给圣母的教堂。有趣的是，
that's told about the defense of Moscow in the Second World War. Because it's said that Stalin sends up an icon of the Virgin in a plane that flies around the city limits of Moscow. So there is these kind of strange inheritances that pass down through the centuries. So I think Athena is a wonderful god and a worthy winner. And I'm very happy that she is. You're with Sigmund Freud on that.
雅典娜守护着雅典娜城的高墙，所以当雅典娜城遭到袭击时，人们可以看到她在城墙上走动、巡逻。我知道你要说什么了——君士坦丁堡。所以，当城市遭到围困时，人们看到圣母显灵，在君士坦丁堡巡视，保卫君士坦丁堡。这个传统后来流传到了关于第二次世界大战中莫斯科保卫战的民间传说中。因为据说斯大林派了一架飞机载着圣母像，在莫斯科城市边缘巡飞。所以，有这样一些奇怪的传承历经数个世纪流传下来。因此，我认为雅典娜是一位伟大的神，也是一个实至名归的赢家。我很高兴她赢了。在这点上你和西格蒙德·弗洛伊德（Sigmund Freud）看法一致。
Didn't Sigmund Freud have a sculpture of Athena on his desk? Yeah, probably. I certainly have. You're very similar people in many ways. Anyway. Wonderful work to which to end. So that concluded the World Cup of Gods. Athena was the champion. Tom, what have you
西格蒙德·弗洛伊德的办公桌上不是摆着一座雅典娜雕像吗？是的，很可能。我桌上也确实摆着。你们在许多方面都是非常相似的人。无论如何。这是一个以极佳的作品来结束的话题。诸神世界杯到此结束了。雅典娜是冠军。汤姆，从
learned from this process as Alan Sugar would call it? That gods are very weird and that um we tend to have a very one-track sense of what gods should be that um the diversity of belief over the course of the centuries and because the span of the globe um undermines yeah i mean you think there's lots of continuities, but people don't dress up in other people's inverted skins anymore,
这个过程中——正如阿兰·舒格（Alan Sugar）所说的那样——你学到了什么？神非常古怪，而且，嗯，我们往往对神应该是什么样有着非常单一的看法。几个世纪以来信仰的多样性，以及由于地球的广袤，削弱了——我的意思是，你以为存在很多延续性，但人们不再穿着别人的反面兽皮了，
do they, as the Chibitotech? I mean, I still think it's a tragedy that Prince Philip didn't win. Would have been very good for Britain, good for the Queen. Nice in a tough time, but it wasn't to be. Clearly the public thought otherwise, and the voters, I suppose, are never wrong. So Athena was the champion and we'll have to do another World Cup in a few months.
不是吗，就像奇奇特卡人（Chibitotech）那样？我的意思是，我仍然觉得菲利普亲王没有赢是一场悲剧。这对英国、对女王都会非常有利。在艰难时期这会很美好，但事与愿违。显然公众有不同的看法，而且我想选民永远是不会错的。所以雅典娜是冠军，几个月后我们还得再办一次世界杯。
Tom, got any ideas? I think Kings and Queens of Britain. I think it would be brilliant. Brilliant. Maybe American presidents. Okay. Jolly good. I still look forward to it.
汤姆，有什么想法吗？我觉得可以选英国的国王和女王。我觉得这会非常精彩。非常精彩。也许可以选美国总统。好的。太棒了。我依然充满期待。
We shall... We've got some great episodes coming up. We've got Magna Carta coming up. We've got Mohammed. Which is topical because he was a great toppler of idols. So in a way, a kind of perfect follow-up to this. See you next time.
我们将会……我们接下来会有一些很棒的剧集。我们要讲《大宪章》。我们要讲穆罕默德。这很应景，因为他是一位伟大的破除偶像者。所以从某种意义上说，这可以说是对本期节目的完美续集。下次见。
Bye-bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拜拜。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听加长版节目、提前解锁、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。